all right guys
bang bang i've got jack here with me
thanks so much for doing this man yeah
of course
fun to be here thank you you're a
fascinating guy because
you are uh an investor but you don't
invest in outside companies you invest
in companies that
you and your partners and your team
create internally so
pure incubation yeah uh one of those
businesses i want to start off with just
to explain the model
is hims which is a multi-billion dollar
company that you guys
took public recently yeah walk us
through how do you go from
an idea to hey we have a multi-billion
dollar business
at sitting in like an investor seat
right yeah it's a great question
you know at this point i started atomic
with my own capital in 2012 we've been
scaling it up
and one of the biggest lessons i'd say
that we've learned is that
distribution is actually more important
than ideas so
ideas are only worth you know anything
if they reach a ton of people
customers businesses whoever you're kind
of targeting so we have kind of
mastered at atomic testing distribution
even before we create companies so
hims was an exercise of the healthcare
system can use a lot of work i mean it's
pretty broken in a lot of areas it's
unfortunate
33 cents of every dollar in the economy
goes through it and
people are actually you know life
expectancies going down
so we were trying to think about you
know what are ways that we can improve
that telemedicine is an obvious one
that's really interesting
and we tested a number of ideas and um
believe it or not hair loss just tested
off the charts i mean it was absolutely
incredible how much demand there was
for hair loss and when you study that
market it was really interesting
there's like 50 million men in the
united states that suffer from hair loss
and there's a drug or a couple of drugs
that work extremely well to treat it
that are actually not that expensive
and only 50 000 people at the time were
taking it this is like propecia
uh whatever these other ones are yeah
exactly exactly so
you're sort of like why aren't people
taking these things like are they not
aware of them what's going on and
it turns out you know and one of the
things that we found in telemedicine in
general is that
stigmatized conditions things that
people are embarrassed about that they
don't necessarily want to go to their
doctor about and talk about
those tend to be very under-treated and
hair loss was kind of like a really
really good beachhead for men's health
overall
where you have so many people that are
suffering from it you have such a good
treatment that works really well with
like very minimal side effects
and the interest in it was just like
astounding i mean we knew we had kind of
struck gold just based on those
distribution tests we did early on and
from there we just set out to build it
we built it extremely quickly we
launched it
and within about three years of launch a
little over three years we took it
public for
about a three billion dollar market cap
which is pretty incredible
and the company continues to grow and
scale and you know it's taking on
new things we've launched hers we're
doing women's health now too
but that's an example of if you get the
distribution part of it right
you can build a really really big
company really quickly so it's funny
that you're talking about this because
uh over the weekend i saw a couple of
friends
and uh hair loss came up yeah and
um for a while i've always said that
propecia and i forget the other
uh pill is widespread
among men between like 25 35 years old
but none of them talk about it with each
other
it's not like i think kind of it's known
that women are very collaborative in
terms of recommending products and like
all this stuff to each other
but men not so much yeah uh and then as
men kind of phase out and they start to
try to have kids and all this stuff then
they start looking oh should i still
take it should i not and whatever
but when you talk about testing the
distribution right so 50 million men
okay you probably google and figure out
you know how many people suffer from
hair loss
how do you actually start to test how
many people already taking this what's
the actual interest right because one
thing anecdotally oh my friends talk
about it
but how do you actually scientifically
understand is this worth pursuing as an
idea or not
yeah it's a great question you know at
the time there had been sort of this
telemedicine 1.0 so you might have heard
of companies like teledoc it's an
incredible company it's doing well it's
a public company
i'd invested in a company called doctor
on demand as an angel investor
and what those companies created is this
idea of the virtual doctor visit
so kind of like primary care you're sick
you need something you instead of going
to an office you go to an app and they
treat you for things
and our thesis was well you know the
thing you really learn about consumers
on the internet is they're activated by
like very specific pain points
okay so in that case you're competing
with the waiting room you're competing
with the process of getting employment
all of that stuff
as opposed to acute things people are
suffering from so if you advertise those
things that people are suffering from
they're much more likely to connect with
them and then what if you use
telemedicine as a vehicle
to diagnose them confirm whether or not
they have that and confirm whether or
not the treatment is going to work for
them
and then you deliver care through the
internet i mean it's just a much much
more scalable model it makes a lot of
sense
so we ran a lot of ads early on
to test these various conditions that
could catch fire like that
and you know hair loss just tested off
the charts as being something really
interesting
some something people were aware of they
wanted to do something about it but for
whatever reason they weren't going to
the doctor
and that's kind of this almost
telemedicine 2.0 model of
focus on the condition use telemedicine
to
diagnose it and then treat people
digitally what you're really talking
about here is one of the most important
things if not the most important thing
when starting a business is picking the
right market yeah right
and so you're essentially in a very kind
of methodical way saying okay we think
telemedicine's interesting
but we're not going to put capital and
time and resources behind this until we
really understand
exactly what we're going to go do and so
do you basically just sit around in a
room and you're like all right let's
brainstorm what's the
50 things that potentially telemedicine
could solve and then like let's create
ad creative and and
go and actually test it all and then
we'll kind of put it through a funnel
and okay this is the thing is that
kind of how it worked um you know it
depends on the
the case most of the things that we
start are actually problems that we
observe so believe it or not at atomic
despite the fact we've started dozens of
companies i don't know if we've ever had
a brainstorming session okay interesting
i actually think brainstorming sessions
can lead to contrived ideas that
aren't as good as there's a problem in
the world a lot of people are suffering
from something
how do you solve it and thinking
creatively about how to solve it and
focus on the solution and test the
solution
make sure it is as big of a problem that
you thought it was and that that is the
right solution for the problem
so you know we have like 600 ideas for
companies at this point
a lot of those are observed problems in
the world they could be problems people
have they could be problems companies
have
they could be problems in specific
industries like healthcare real estate
finance education etc etc we work across
all of those
markets but um it's usually observing a
problem is a much much better way to
start a company
than kind of contrived brainstorming you
said you have 600 ideas today
is that like a is there like a master
doc and you literally just keep putting
them in there and then you guys
prioritize and decide which one to work
on next or like how does that work
yeah there's a master doc um it exists
it's in an evernote file and we kind of
work off of that
and you know increasingly as atomic
increases and we have more and more
employees across our companies and
across our firm
people also contribute ideas which is
great venture capitalists sometimes come
to us with ideas they'll say
hey we've studied this market we think
that there's something here we've looked
at
10 companies we don't think any of them
are doing it right hey
jack and team like if you could build
this company we would love to fund it
and partner on the series a so that's
another way that we do it
um and then b2b companies interestingly
a lot of our most successful b2b
companies have come from solving
problems of our existing portfolio
and that's great because you know it's a
problem you can observe it
and you have a built-in customer base to
kind of dog food it perfect the product
before you get it out there in the world
and that's been a really effective way
for us to build b2b
companies so atomic is kind of like its
own self-perpetuating ecosystem in a way
where
as we start more companies they they
have more problems we can solve those
problems using technology
as we enter more markets like healthcare
we discover all these
adjacencies and new white spaces that
lead to more ideas
you know software is eating the world
it's like the biggest thing that's
happening in the world
people don't talk about it enough and
the problem is as people from the
technology industry
we don't always understand those
industries we don't know how they
operate we don't know why we don't you
know they
we might observe that they're messed up
but we don't know why once you're
in that industry you understand it's so
much better you understand the players
why is it backward why was the system
created this way
and in doing that and understanding that
it actually yields a lot of ideas on how
to fix it and make it better
how does atomic work so maybe we could
start with like
why you started it and then the
evolution of it because it's
a fascinating model right you're
essentially acting as a venture
capitalist but
uh you're getting to say yes or no to
the ideas that are started
versus other people coming and just
pitch you you know hey i started a
company now i'm raising a series a and
you kind of are almost seeing a snapshot
in time versus actually being there from
day one of the creation of the business
yeah it's a great question well i got my
start
pretty early i started starting
companies at age 15.
my dad came to the us to get his phd at
mit without a dollar to his name slept
on a concrete basement floor and a
sleeping bag because he couldn't afford
housing so
where was he from um he moved across the
world he was actually born in southern
lebanon in a farming
family okay and worked his way to the
best science and engineering school in
france and then
to the us he came here not even speaking
english that well and i saw him kind of
go through this journey you know we kind
of grew up somewhat poor
and then like we you know he had some
success and
started a company and sold it and when i
was 12 or 13 he wanted to start a
company that measured everything
everyone did
on the internet and invited me to join
as a third employee as a software
engineer and that's really where i like
fell in love with technology fell in
love with data saw that grow
your dad hired you to work at his
company yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i was smart back then i took stock
instead of um
cash so that was good oh very probably
because like child labor laws you know i
probably couldn't have gotten paid cash
anyway
but um it ended up working out and i
just got hooked so i started starting
companies at age 15.
um went to wharton undergrad i had a
professor that offered me a half a
million dollars to drop out and start a
company which i took him up on
moved out to the west coast and sold my
first company to ebay when i was 24
years old and
when you're when you're at wharton why
does the professor come to you
specifically
uh what did you already have the idea
just walk through that's a very unique
uh kind of situation in life uh and then
one that you ended up capitalizing on
yeah my experience at wharton was
interesting so i went to public school
and then when i got there i looked
around the room and i was like
these people are really smart
is that more a judgment on the people
around the public school system
well i guess a little bit of both but
you know my freshman year i was like
okay i have to beat these people i have
to prove that i can beat these people so
i just put my head down
i like got near a perfect gpa because i
just i like
hustled i just wanted to make sure i
could beat them and like be the best
and then after that i was kind of like
this is kind of cool but
i don't know how much of this i'm going
to use throughout my life i'm going to
actually just like stop kind of going to
class and start working on ideas and
i kept inventing ways to like not have
to go to class so
one way to not go to class is you do an
independent study with a professor
there's a professor who happened to like
entrepreneurship so i created this
independent study to not have to go to
class to like look into ideas with with
this professor
and i had about 10 different ideas and
we went through them throughout the
course of the semester and at the end he
said
jack like i think this is a great idea
if you want to do it i'll give you a
half a million bucks to get you started
and
i took them up on it i dropped out and
moved out to the west what was the idea
so the idea was so at the time and this
actually continues to be the case
the internet the internet's influence on
offline purchasing is massive so this
sort of research online buy offline
phenomenon
the internet has a massive amount of
information about products how good they
are ratings reviews prices etc
but most of the purchasing still occurs
in the physical economy
and there wasn't a bridge between those
two systems so we created a company
called milo
that searched those stores just like
kayak searches flights and we would
search their inventory systems in real
time
and we tell you here are all the
products that are available near you
here's the ratings here's the reviews
here's who has the best price
and then help you go and actually buy it
at a physical store instead of buy it
online
and a lot of people want instant
gratification they want to see it
they want to look at it they want to ask
questions about it before they buy it so
it was a huge trend it still is a
massive trend it actually accounts for
almost half of commerce this behavior
that exists
and yeah it was a really big idea and i
felt like it was worth
dropping out to go and do it yeah you
end up selling it to ebay
how long do you stay at ebay before you
you can't not go start more companies
yeah so i had a three-year deal with
them where i was supposed to stay
um and i'm just like a big believer in
not wasting
time i've heard so many stories about
founders languishing like after your
company gets acquired and they're
miserable
i'm just not gonna do that i'm gonna
work really hard i'm gonna go try to
like bust my ass and do some really cool
things while i'm here
and try to learn like this was the first
time i could learn on someone else's
dime was how i thought about it
so i started starting tons of these
different product groups under me to
build products for ebay
and a lot of those products hit and they
were working and they did like amazing
things for the company and there was a
lot of press
and some of them drove the stock price
the biggest thing i built 130 million
monthly active users
used um what was that uh it was the feed
so the idea was you know i was an early
investor in pinterest
very early on and this idea of like
discovery commerce ebay is kind of like
almost all the revenue comes from the
search box but there's so much amazing
stuff on ebay so what if you could
create a follower model where you could
follow
safe searches and brands and you know
different people buyers and sellers and
get a feed on the home page and
we built that really quickly and it was
it was an awesome experience while i was
there and
i worked really closely with the ceo
john donahoe while i was there he now
runs nike he's an amazing person he was
a mentor to me
and he was so kind to me that he was
like i you know
after two years of ebay i was like i
don't think i can do the third year
he gave me the third year so real world
works out sometimes
you know if you work really hard people
are nice and he's a
wonderful human being amazing so two
years and then did you know that you
wanted to go start what became atomic
and kind of do like incubation
or how do you go from leaving ebay to
what is now known as atomic
yeah so i had you know the grin on your
face was just a good story here
well you know ebay was in the south bay
and i was living in san francisco so i
had a commute
and during the commute i have just like
an act of mind i'm just like always
thinking about things
listening to things and i got i was you
know maybe every three days i'd come up
with an idea for the company on this
commute for a new company and i wrote it
down
and um you know i took all the other
ideas that i had and by the time i was
ready to leave ebay
250 ideas for my next company and i put
two and two together which was to say
you know hey if i can build these
companies for ebay these products
and you know there's no upside for
anyone that works on them there's a lot
of organizational inertia working
against you and building that
why can't you do that with startups from
first principles you can you know
assemble super teams you can give
everyone upside you can work on huge
problems you don't have to just work in
the sandbox of ebay
it should work from first principles and
then you know of course
the corollary thought to that is okay
250 ideas you're not going to be able to
start them all
how do you find the 10 that matter and
that's kind of been the journey that
i've been on it's just like
how do you test ideas how do you figure
out if they're worth working on
we have such limited time in our lives
how do you just like
work on the very very best stuff given
that we have opportunity cost
and over time that's kind of what we've
perfected in our process um
we hold our time very sacred we think
there's like a huge
power law on how time is spent and we
take only the very best things and we
put a lot behind them we put a lot of
capital in a lot of time
when you have 250 or 600 ideas on a list
uh you can go test you can say hey
telemedicine's interesting let's go run
ads and figure out what in telemedicine
how do you pair down 250 or 600 to
10 right that seems to be almost the
most important thing that you do
because if you're going to spend your
time on something knowing the 10 versus
the 240 or
the 590 is pretty important yeah it's
really important absolutely yeah the
danger of having 250 ideas is man you
can stretch yourself then pretty
pretty quickly so we actually did
something that i'm very proud that we
did
we sort of passed the marshmallow test
so to speak with atomic where
i said the first year we're only gonna
do one company the next year we're gonna
do two
the next year we're gonna do three then
we're gonna do four and then once we
have the infrastructure set up
where we can be convinced that each
subsequent thing we're doing is of
higher quality than the last thing then
we'll scale it but we're not going to do
it prematurely
and there are kind of two processes that
we've found to identify what those
opportunities are
one is we just find someone we love and
we just like want to work with them and
it
doesn't matter what idea we work on
together and we'll open up this list of
you know hundreds of ideas
we'll pick 10 to 15 that we mutually
think are interesting and then we
activate this playbook that we've
developed over time of how to
test these ideas because those people
also don't want to waste their time they
only want to work on big ideas
and through that process if we find one
and only if we find one that we think is
super super compelling
then we take all the data all of the
research and we say okay we're going to
start it
we fund it with a quarter million
dollars typically and then we test
any remaining questions behind the idea
before putting millions of dollars into
it and then
tens of millions and more beyond that so
that's one way we do it
second way we do it is my partners and i
we've all started billion dollar
companies before
and you know we're good at building
products ourselves so if we're really
passionate about something we'll really
drive it internally we have about 40
people at atomic
that are expert company builders and if
we find something that's really great
we'll start it we'll build the product
we'll try to get it to some semblance of
scale it could be millions of dollars of
revenue it could be
in some cases been as high as like 25
million in bookings and then
our job is to replace ourselves like our
model does not work if we run the
company so
we will get them working and then we'll
try to find the perfect person in the
world
to run it and we will make them ceo and
we'll make them a co-founder and we'll
give them a co-founding stake
even though it's already working because
we want them to feel like they are a
true co-founder and they have ownership
over
the idea the product the culture they
get to hire out their own team and we
kind of start taking a little bit of a
step back
which is what i think really talented
people want i think they want autonomy i
don't think they
want people breathing down their necks
and you know that method
has been very very effective and
something that we've continued to
develop and lean into
from a data perspective how many
companies you said there's about 40
people
how much money you think you've invested
what do you think like the total
portfolio just whatever data you're
comfortable sharing in terms of just
like
progress or like how well it's gone
yeah it's gone really well um we've
started
a couple dozen companies at this point
last year was a prolific year
for us we started almost a company a
month so now we really feel like we have
this platform we have this playbook
we're confident that we're not deleting
ourselves we have the leverage to be
able to
build these companies without um
you know the risk of getting stuck with
something that we're gonna have to work
on for a long time
we don't when we raise capital we don't
want to lose people's money we do not
want to lose people's money we like hold
that
really really sacred so it's fine if we
lose money as a fund
because we can take the people and we
can put them on a better idea and we're
aligned with our investors in that
but if we're signed up and we raise
outside capital from people
we're going to try to make it work come
hell or high water so it's a really
really high bar that we have internally
for
deciding ultimately what we we want to
work on
and when you think about um maybe
something like open store
which is a new company that uh you and
keith boy
uh have uh worked together on to launch
how does that come together
and then maybe walk us through like i
don't know maybe you're 90 days 120 days
into this thing right just like
like getting to the point of okay we're
doing this
we have a team and like we're moving
towards a launch
yeah um it's a good question so and that
one may be an outlier
but still yeah no it wasn't too much of
an outlier i mean there are a couple of
things that are different about it but
the observation of the problem which is
how we come up with a lot of our ideas
came from
i was mentoring a female entrepreneur
that had started a company
and she came to me and the first
question she asked me was really
interesting she asked me
how do i sell my company and i said
that's interesting you know most people
don't ask me that typically that's not
typically the first question
okay like let's go into the business
more and she said
you know we develop organic skincare
products 85
gross margin i said great how many
people come back and purchase your
product
88 of them come back wow fantastic they
come back to your site they put in their
credit card number over and over again
she was like yeah they do i was like
okay it works it work that's awesome
good for you and like how do you get
your customers do you do marketing
oh you know i kind of do marketing
sometimes but like i don't really like
doing it because
i like just the cash flow of the company
i said okay interesting and what's the
top line revenue and how much would you
be willing to sell for
and she said three to four million top
line and she'd probably be willing to
sell for one x or a little bit more
so i thought wow that's really
interesting this seems like a good
business you know
if you owned a company like this there's
so many ways you could like make it a
lot better and take these amazing
products you developed and distribute
them
across the world in a more efficient way
so then i thought
well what if you created a website to
answer that question you know
how do i sell my business what's it
worth should i sell it
and you know keith had founded open door
which is an incredible company that's
public where you can go to a website you
can put in your address they give you an
offer to buy your house
what if you did the same thing for
having someone buy your company that
would be pretty cool
so that's kind of the journey we set out
to embark on
we're doing a little bit of work on it
atomic and i love keith keith is
amazing i mean he's one of the most
talented people in the world i think
he invested in milo my first company so
i've known him for a really long time
there's actually a funny story of how we
got to know each other originally
but i you know love keith and thought he
would be the perfect person to work on
with this
and talk with them about it and you know
we kind of evolved the idea from there
and
added a lot to it and keith has so such
a breadth of expertise in this area
i said you know why don't we co-found
this together and we decided to co-found
it earlier this year
um it started you know neither of us
really had office space so everyone was
working out of my house until like
midnight every day and
my girlfriend eventually got a little
tired of that
engineer and people throughout the house
so now you know
it's funded we have an office we're
scaling it it's really exciting it's an
amazing phase of growth for the company
and
i really think that it can be a massive
massive company and it's a lot of fun to
work together with keith on it
it's unique because he's the ceo he's
also venture capitalist he's funded a
ton of uh
great businesses he's co-founded a bunch
of great businesses you have as well
how do you think about building a team
early especially when
uh it frankly sounds like there's
multiple people around the table that
could lead the business as the ceo or as
an executive
and then on top of that you also have
this 40
odd you know number of people who are
kind of experts at company building
right and so it's almost like in some
weird way there's tons of expertise
there's tons of capabilities tons of uh
experience from the table
but somebody's got to be the ceo
somebody's got to do the work et cetera
like how do you kind of think through
evaluating that in that situation yeah
it was it was an interesting
conversation
you know we were like should we be
co-ceo should we someone else be ceo how
how do we kind of go about this and
um you know we settled on uh keith being
the ceo which is awesome
and i'm super super supportive of that
and
i think one of the amazing things about
keith is he has such
an incredible eye for talent he can
basically sit down
with an and within five minutes of
talking to someone know if they're gonna
be really good it's like an
extraordinary
superpower that he has and it's been
really fun to collaborate and identify
like who are the
absolute best people in the world to
start this company with
we just set a really high bar and we
went after them
and we've assembled this team that like
you couldn't even imagine like even
before we had money
in the company like an unbelievable team
to go after this
and you know from me start building so
many companies and investing personally
in him
you know investing in so many companies
and operating and what and what not
you really learn like okay who do you
need in the team who's missing
how are we going to find them and you
know so
many of the conversations early on have
been how do we assemble this super team
who's missing how do we get them
and we've prioritized that and we've
been very successful in building an
awesome team so far
um i had dinner with him and a couple of
other folks
shortly after people started to hear
that this was happening
and uh he said on multiple occasions
we just hired and you know the best uh
gc i've worked with or the best this or
whatever
and it just struck me i know that he's
always said you know the people you hire
is kind of the company you build
but uh seeing it in practice almost in
real time was
fascinating because it literally felt
like uh you
him and whoever else sat down and kind
of looked at the rolodex and said okay
we need a gc right who's the best that
we know and i'm like okay let's just go
get them yeah and i think that there's a
a difference because i know that him and
i'd be interested to hear your thoughts
on this
uh keith specifically thinks about um
you don't have to iterate yourself your
way to success like you can just say hey
the world needs this and like you can go
build it yeah
uh and so same thing with talent right
of just like that's the best person
we're gonna go do whatever it takes to
go hire them to come join us
and so from a product development
standpoint are you kind of the similar
mindset or do you do more kind of
iteration
and because you come from like a testing
right you know mentality or model
to find the idea once you have the idea
how much of its iterative versus
kind of more like we're going to bend
the world to us
yeah it's a good question you know
different ideas scale for different
reasons
the constraints on open store the two
constraints are technology and capital
that's really it and the world's your
oyster there's 13 to 15 million
merchants in the world that we can work
with and capital being the capital
needed to purchase the businesses
to purchase the businesses okay which is
a lot yep and then the technology
explain what the the limitations there
are
uh the technology to underwrite the
companies to
put them on a common platform to improve
them over time i mean
we're great at building technology
that's like in both of our sweet spots
so
we understand that very very well so
those two things actually don't seem
tremendously risky and it's pretty
obvious if you get those right you're
going to have a really really really big
company
so it made sense to go and raise a lot
of capital and get the right team
together and just really go big
after it particularly because you need
a certain amount of capital to prove out
this model um
50 million 100 million i mean more
potentially
some of our other companies you can
actually start them and
really what determines whether or not
they're going to scale and become big
companies is this distribution question
and distribution is now that we live in
an internet era of gatekeepers there's
facebook there's google and
you have to acquire customers either
through marketing or sales
so we iterate so much on the unit
economics and you can actually we
figured out ways to do that
very very inexpensively with limited
amounts of capital
and once we've nailed that and only once
we've nailed that
then do we decide to scale the company
up and actually
in that process if that's kind of what
you're trying to optimize for
sometimes having too much resources too
many cooks in the kitchen
it can actually be distracting and like
finding the way to get this thing to
scale
once it scales once it goes from zero to
one where you found product market fit
and you're going to the one to end
you know scale strategy then you raise a
lot of capital and you go and you blitz
the market
and so it just depends on the idea and
you know
what does it take to get started this is
a company with a high ticket of entry
to start hey guys what's going on before
we continue with this awesome episode i
want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10 dollars
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app you'll have your
portfolio
in your pocket you can track your
portfolio see who the winners and losers
are every day
track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
kraken's been a longtime supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go and
download their new mobile app
all right let's get back into this
episode i hope you're enjoying this one
when you think of distribution over
ideas that's a very unique way of
thinking about it there's a um
kind of an old saying i don't know paul
graham or whoever is like first-time
entrepreneurs focus on the product
second time entrepreneurs focus on uh
kind of distribution
right when you talk about distribution
is it just total adjustable market is it
your ability to communicate with that
market
is it a cost thing right like unpack a
little bit distribution and kind of what
that means and how you think about
oh this has great distribution and
therefore we should go pursue it versus
maybe something that
people may think has great distribution
but would be a red flag to you
yeah there's really two things i mean
one is the scalability
the channels that exist to reach
customers and because we've operated so
many companies we understand
all of the channels to reach customers
and we know what works in them we know
it doesn't work in them
so we know how to test them even before
you scale them up
so you test the channel see if it works
and then you test the scalability of the
channel which is really important you
don't want to build something that looks
good early on
sometimes facebook's algorithm will
trick you and make you think you have a
great company and then
you get it to you know sum millions of
revenue and it kind of peters out
scalability is really really really
important and it's related to
broadly how big of a problem you're
solving if you're solving a really big
problem and it's going to resonate with
a lot of people
you're going to reach a ton of people
and you're going to improve a lot of
people's lives and it's going to be a
great company
and when you think through let's say the
scalability almost the sustainability
of unit economics or the scalability of
something
how much of that is you can actually
just put money and kind of experience to
work and quickly figure it out
versus literally it just takes time
right and so it's a six month or a 12
month exercise to actually understand
the scalability or the sustainability
yeah it is very difficult so the common
problem with startups right is like you
have an idea you go and you raise money
from
friends and family or whatever and then
you're like a year in you have to raise
a little bit more money and two years in
you kind of have this product and you
try to get it out there and nine times
out of ten startups fail
because they hit that distribution wall
so we just
pull that wall up to day zero and we say
if we can't get through that wall
we're not even gonna start the company
we almost don't care if this is a good
idea in the abstract
we want to work on ideas that matter and
that's really you know kind of the focus
and
the secret of how we've we've been able
to scale so many companies so quickly
and each successive company is scaling
faster than the last it's reaching
million dollar arr you know some kind of
milestone that we
say as product market fit earlier
earlier than ever
and you know our ambition is to to scale
things really quickly and make progress
really quickly
how do you think through um business
models right so one of the things that's
fascinating to me
is uh in many of the companies that you
guys have started
uh in hindsight great alignment between
multiple kind of parties in a
transaction or in a business
it feels like some businesses get off
the ground quickly
they've got what appears to be
scalability they've got distribution
but there's some misalignment there's
some place where the business actually
is
you know greedy in hindsight um
but it seems like you guys have really
nailed down how to avoid that and so
just
how do you think about okay hair loss
great that's a huge problem telemedicine
we think is the solution
how do we make money right how do we
actually build a business model that is
scalable sustainable
but aligns everyone here so that we
don't get three years down the road and
realize that somebody else came up and
kind of stole
the customers we did all that market
education etc yeah there are a few
metrics that are really important to
optimize early on in a company's history
the most
important one is the payback period on
spend so
if you put money into acquiring
customers how quickly do you get paid
back the lower that number the better
because you can scale faster and you can
recycle capital and you can scale the
company really quickly and ultimately
what you're looking for is you know an
ltv to calc metric of you know what's
the lifetime value of customer
relative to how much it costs you to get
them and if you start off with you know
the cac down here and the ltv
way up here you have a lot of room for
error so we try to look for companies
like that
if we're doing testing and they're a
little bit closer to here or they're
like here
we're just not going to start the
company we have 600 ideas we have such
high opportunity costs for our time we
just don't want to be working on it
is there a magic number like is it a
four times ltv to cac
and you're like okay if we're there or
better than like that's a green light
or is it more kind of case by case and
you got to kind of feel out based on the
type of business the ticket size etc
it's a little case by case i think best
in class is like you're getting paid
back in three months or less
okay which we've figured out how to do
for a lot of our companies
and the ltv to cac is above five to
start
because unit economics can decay a
little bit as you scale so you
want to give yourself some room of
course you're going to continue to
improve the product it's going to get
better
people are going to get more value out
of it so you know there will be an
offsetting force to that
but starting with those bars pretty far
away from each other
is really smart because you give
yourself a lot of wiggle room yeah makes
sense
uh another theme uh other than
distribution over ideas is
democratization
democratization of access uh you can see
this in
a ton of stuff that you guys have done
yeah um just
any thoughts or insights there in terms
of why that's such a big theme that
you're focused on
yeah it's something that we're really
passionate about you know i think that
one of the great patterns for ideas is
taking things that
the rich have access to whether that's
like people
or its companies and how do you make it
cheaper
and distribute it to more people and
give people access to that thing
so uber is a great example of that right
i mean their rich people would pay for
drivers and they'd sit around all day
and like sit outside their house and you
know you'd have a driver that could take
you point to point whenever you wanted
and they said
okay how do we take this and how do we
democratize it how do we give
more people access to this and they
brought it down and they brought the
cost down
over time while increasing the quality
of the experience
and now everyone uses it in the world
and everyone basically has a private
driver where you can press a button on
your phone when a car shows up which is
magical so we think about the world a
lot
in that way we try to buy we try to we
try to start a lot of companies that
take things that people already want but
that are very expensive
and how do we make them cheap and how do
we make them accessible and how do we
give that kind of an experience or
product to a lot of people
and it's almost always a recipe for a
good company
because if people aspirationally want it
already and it exists but it's just
too expensive if you can figure out a
way to make it cheaper and
better at the same time it's gonna it's
gonna get distribution a lot of people
are gonna be interested in that yeah
a lot of what we're talking about here
is what i would consider more of the
like
analytical approach to company building
right yes it's being intelligent about
how i spend your time it's being very
kind of ruthless in prioritization but
there's work that needs to be done yeah
right like
so great we can sit around we can look
at 600 ideas here's the one that we like
we went we tested it looks great
what do the 40 people at atomic do right
are these all software engineers and
it's you know
there uh somebody comes off the mountain
and says hey we're gonna go build this
company and they all get to work
is it kind of a more well-rounded team
of like various disciplines just
it's a pretty big team to kind of do
this over and over and over again so
what exactly do they do on a day-to-day
basis
yeah it's a good question so a lot of
the most talented people
in the world that i know they can't
actually just
work on one idea it's like
a little too boring you know like
they're just their
processing bandwidth is so high that
they can handle so many things and
they're actually
best when they're doing a lot of things
i almost think about like human beings
in an interesting way where
if you ever open up activity monitor on
the mac or do control alt delete or
whatever on like a windows machine
the processor is always humming at 10
it's capable of so much but it's always
a 10
because you're always doing word
processing or you're surfing the
internet or something like that
at atomic we figured out how to rev the
human processor from like 10
to like 30 or maybe 40 percent because
people are capable of so much if you
give them the opportunity to work on
high value things
and it turns out a lot of the most
talented people in the world want that
they
you know they don't want to be bored
they want to be engaged they want to
work on really big things
that matter so we've tried to find the
very best people
in design engineering but also things
like
you know things entrepreneurs don't tend
to like to deal with which is really a
great way to
take things off their plate legal
accounting
um finance hr recruiting ops bd
we we do a lot as you'd imagine around
distributions we have great people in
marketing we have great people at sales
and those people are kind of functional
experts at what they do
that normally would not work on an early
stage company
it's there's not enough for them to do
the company probably couldn't pay for
them because they're pretty expensive
because they're really good at what they
do
so if you take them and you spread them
across companies you can bring a swat
team of like
amazing people to day zero in your
company building
that know what they're doing this is
what they do they do it in their sleep
and you can build incredibly quickly
when they come and they do this how much
of it
is okay in the beginning i'm actually
doing the work let's say i'm an expert
at sales right
i'm doing the work six months later i'm
helping to hire somebody to come in and
by month 12 now i'm a coach
right is that kind of a natural
progression for somebody who's like has
a specific expertise on the atomic team
yeah it is a natural progression we view
our job as like
we have to do so much work up front
because if we get it right
the company is actually going to need us
less and that's how our model scales
like
we can't be like micromanaging people
it's just not going to work so
we do so much work up front to make the
company
architected well get the right dna into
the company
and if we're successful in doing that
the truth is the companies start taking
off and they
need us less and less so it's a gradual
progression
um but a lot of companies do choose to
continue using like this shared team of
services that we provide
because it lets them stay focused on the
things that actually really matter about
companies which is
the product the customer how do you
solve the problem how do you get that to
scale as opposed to these other 18 hats
you typically
have to wear as a founder and it
actually takes kind of like
a lot of the things that people don't
enjoy about company building and they
just get to focus on the fun stuff which
is the product and the customer and
building something that matters yeah
you're doing all this in miami
uh most people know others who have been
yelling and screaming about miami uh for
good reason yeah i live in miami yeah
me too you are the uh i think patient
zero
yes it's probably the best way to
describe this of the
tech uh kind of boom uh at least the
recent one
in miami tell us a story as to what the
hell were you doing in miami last year
why did you stay and then how did you
convince some of the early folks to uh
to go ahead and come check it out and
end up moving here
yeah so um you know i had a bunch of
friends
that were trying to convince me for a
while to come to miami and hey let's
spend a week together
seven friends primarily from new york
why don't you come join us and
finally i gave in i was like okay we'll
we'll do the miami trip so
we did the miami trip we're supposed to
stay for seven days and
four days into the trip i actually got
covet oh okay
which was unfortunate um you know i kept
testing positive for about a month and a
half for on the pcr test so i was
basically
it wasn't like terrible for me or
anything like that but i didn't feel
comfortable flying back to california
you know i didn't
want to spread it on a plane and this is
like march or april of last year
this was june of last year okay um so my
friends and i we kept renting like other
houses in different areas our airbnb's
kept expiring so we're kind of like
these nomads moving around the city
and as a result i got to see all the
communities here and all the amazing
places to live and who's here
and i just fell in love with the city i
just said man this place is absolutely
incredible
and in july i found a house i like to
put in an offer was in contract
bought a place in august and from that
point forward you know i just regularly
catch up with people on zooms
you know a lot of people who runs you
know big firms big venture capital firms
a lot of founders things like that
and the perennial question you always
got during kovid was where are you
so people say where are you and i'd say
miami and they'd say miami why are you
in why
am i this is before miami it's hot right
so i felt the need to explain myself
a little bit defend yourself defend
myself yeah
so i just told them honestly like why i
thought miami was such an amazing place
and almost all of them moved here
afterward really which was pretty
incredible
and since then they've brought tons of
people so i probably directly recruited
you know two or three dozen people not
on purpose by the way
just telling them here's why i did it
here's why i think it's great and why i
think it's interesting
was it because they were looking for
somewhere to go or was it like they were
running almost like running from
something
or running to something or maybe it's a
mix
um it probably was a little bit of a mix
you know i think
one of the most important things like
historically as we look at this period
of coved that it did
for the united states is it decoupled
location and opportunity it used to be
you had to live in a specific area to
participate in opportunity
in the economy and that led to all sorts
of problems like housing prices being
crazy you know a lot of people can't get
access to that because they're priced
out
and now i think distributed works remote
works and people started realizing wow
i'm actually really effective over zoom
maybe i'm
more effective or resume i mentioned to
you last year we started about a company
a month
a company a month that's more than any
point in our history
so i realized wow i can be more
productive and miami's absolutely
incredible
and it seems like everyone wants to move
here let's get to where the puck's going
and you know not just stay behind and i
think a lot of people had the same
thought
they gave it up they gave it a try and
they said wow this is incredible
and there are massive advantages to
being here i mean we're
more productive than we've ever been
we're building more faster than we ever
have and
i'm a big believer in the ecosystem and
how it can be a big part of the future
of technology yeah oh so people i'm
happier here
yeah and yeah it's a weird thing to say
it feels kind of woo-woo
like you know yeah yeah what does that
mean totally uh but there's this balance
i think that uh in new york and san
francisco
a lot of people do the same thing where
uh you would go to work
you would be there all day you would
literally leave and you'd go home
and then you were too exhausted to go do
anything or whatever
and then you would like live for the
weekend right yeah then you would like
go out on the weekend get drunk
lose half of the next day because you're
hungover and rocky or whatever
right and then you like do that again
and then next you know like three years
went by
yeah yeah you're like oh my god what
have i been doing my life totally
totally here
i think there's almost like a more
efficiency like a higher efficiency so
you get more done
but it's actually in somewhat of a
shorter time period and then it almost
feels like you like
go on vacation when you leave the office
it's back and do it again
it's incredible it's like the quality of
life here is
so high relative to any other place i've
at least been exposed to in the united
states
and yeah you're absolutely right i mean
my girlfriend and i joke like
if we want to go on vacation we can
drive 10 minutes to the beach and
literally like the way miami works is
you can get the beach chairs and
everything
like even if you're not staying at the
hotel so you can go and drive for 10
minutes and have that kind of an
experience whenever you want
and when you're working really hard you
do need a little bit of an ability to
unplug
and the magic i think is work hard play
hard a little bit in our model and being
able to unplug and
i think that works really well in miami
but i completely agree like i was just
so struck by how happy people are here
yeah and it's not just
certain people it's like everyone is
happy here i
i do think the sun has a huge play into
it like
which sounds stupid and everyone laughs
whatever but
i try every day to go for a walk outside
yeah and uh i did this during covet in
new york
yeah you go outside you feel good
whatever for whatever reason
walking and the sun shining and all this
stuff
you just feel different and i think that
uh that's why when people come visit
they stay yeah or they're like oh i
gotta do this right is
you can talk about it all you want and
somebody comes and actually experiences
it and some of it's the energy
some of it's oh there's real people here
you know whatever totally totally yeah
but i think at home is just like oh the
sun like hit my face i'm like
yeah i want to do this every day i mean
sunlight's magical like we're human
beings we're actually like
meant to be in the sun there's all these
chemical things that happen
with the sun the sun hits your eyes and
like it actually produces chemicals that
make you happy if you live in a place
that
doesn't have a lot of sunshine there's
something called seasonal like
depressive disorders yeah
sad or something like that and here you
get the sun
you can be outside and i think another
thing that i've really enjoyed is i work
all day so i'm inside
and then at night you can go outside and
it's actually nice
outside at night and you can enjoy the
outdoors and you can be outside as well
which i think is really compelling yeah
um
crypto i know you've got some unique
thoughts there uh
have you guys done anything how do you
think about that industry specifically
um is it a different skill set than what
you have do you guys see opportunity
there
yeah crypto is absolutely massive
obviously i mean it's
changing the world in so many different
ways i think that
you know one macro question with crypto
like if we fast forward 10 years from
now and we look at crypto
crypto does take capital and resources
out of our financial system
so you know normally like you go and you
put money in the bank the bank goes and
lets people buy homes or start companies
and lends the money out and kind of
makes it really productive
and i think you know in crypto it's kind
of like buying gold
so you buy gold but that money isn't
in the economy anymore in an interesting
way so i'm
really excited about some of the defy
stuff that's happening
um you know personally i'm a huge fan of
projects like luna and tara
that for example take crypto assets and
then
actually make them investable or let
people lend them out or you can invest
in stocks and you can put it back into
the economy
i think that that's kind of a really
interesting bridge that crypto's going
through right now
that's happening and i think over the
next five ten years it's going to be
really really important that that
continues to happen and accelerates
yeah is there things that you think uh
you guys are uniquely positioned to do
there
or is it something where when you start
getting into protocols and
decentralization and some of the things
that make
uh kind of bitcoin and crypto unique uh
that's outside of
kind of the focus that you guys have in
terms of company building right or
or could one day atomic build a protocol
and
you know kind of go that direction we
could absolutely build a protocol
i have so many ideas in crypto i think
it's a really interesting area we are
terrified to touch it you know why
i don't want to i don't want to break
the law i don't want to go to jail
from a regulatory standpoint you're
scared or you're nervous maybe it's the
better way to put it
yeah i don't know like is it worth we
have so much good stuff going on is it
worth risking that
we would like to do it you know maybe
it's a matter if we need to get smarter
about kind of how to go about doing that
we always
kind of want to do things by the book as
much as we possibly can
so it's just been we've been a little
nervous and
there's so much opportunity in company
building that
it's hard to get away from that but who
knows maybe there will be opportunities
to partner on things in cool ways or do
interesting things i mean there's
tremendous opportunity it's still in its
infancy there
there's so many places it's going to go
from here and it's really important
i actually think it's a little
unfortunate that the us has taken such a
hard stance on it because a lot of
innovation is happening in other parts
of the globe as a result of that
but that's a key consideration that
we're thinking about
got it uh before we get into rapid fire
to finish off yeah uh i want to talk
about
like your motivation yeah so if you look
at kind of uh
your career yeah you start at a very
young age yeah i've had a lot of success
building companies
yeah now creating these businesses uh by
every stretch of the imagination
uh you've accomplished more than most
people would want to accomplish in a
career
you've been very very successful why are
you still doing this
right like like when you wake up every
day right there's a lot of people who
would just be like
i'm good yeah why are you still doing it
yeah it's an interesting question and it
is a question i
get increasingly oh really okay yeah
which is interesting
um you know the reality is like i sold
my first company at 24 i could have
you know invested and stayed on a beach
the rest of my life and like live
some happy life or something like that
to me impact is really really motivating
and the best question the best litmus
test
i've figured out for determining impact
is answering the question
of what would not have happened had i
not been born
and it actually makes me really happy to
know that there are a lot of
major major things that have happened
because i exist
and i want to be able to continue that
and atomic is a platform that we've
launched dozens of companies so far
over time maybe we could launch hundreds
it's possible it could spawn
thousands of companies we invented the
studio model in the tech industry
very early on a lot of people have
replicated that
if i didn't invent that it might not
have happened those have created
thousands of companies we've helped
innovate and create new industries and
all sorts of interesting things
so impact is really interesting and
i am actually interested in that i'm
happiest when i'm working on
new ideas with really good people i love
imagining
a better future and like trying to
invent things and trying to work on
things and whiteboarding and you know
that's just the way my mind works i just
need to be very very busy
for like me to be happy which i kind of
get from my dad who's also
done very well who despite not having to
do anything
after you know he took a huge company
public and he's done a lot of amazing
things
he decided to pick up an organic
chemistry textbook
when people are in college if they have
to take organic
organic chemistry they hate it they hate
it it's like the worst
class they could ever take he picked up
textbooks with texts this big
and he would just go and read through
them and now he's designing new drugs
he's just like making new drugs from
scratch he has no background in it
some of them are in clinical trials they
are drugs that can change the world
like meaningfully improve people's lives
and he does it because it makes him
happy and like i don't know you just
have
to me purpose is really important impact
is really important
i want to maximize that as much as
possible over the course of my life
and the other cool thing about taking
that path if you choose to take that
path which is really hard and
takes a lot of work is you get to work
with awesome people
and working with awesome people is
probably the most important thing you
can do i think after you get out of
college the five people you surround
yourself with
that's your continuing education that's
like how you grow that's how you
interact
and atomic is kind of the best thing
that i can think of of how to get
really really really amazing people
together in a room
working on awesome things and i just get
a lot of energy from working with
awesome people so i really enjoy it
is there a way that you measure it like
quantitatively in terms of
impact like you said like what doesn't
exist in the world if i hadn't been born
but uh is there maybe like a goal right
like hey we want to do 100 companies or
we want to
create a certain amount of market cap or
um
you know some other quantitative metric
that isn't just
that didn't exist unless we built it
right like which by itself is super
self-satisfying and
probably makes you very happy um but are
there other ways that you think about
like kind of quantifying it
yeah definitely um i think about it in
terms of like
improving people's lives and like how
did things get better and how did things
change
um it depends on the company in terms of
how that manifests itself sometimes it's
in job creation directly and indirectly
some of the innovations i've done have
led to millions of jobs actually which
is crazy like think about that it's like
stadiums full of people that like have
jobs because
i had this idea and you know i've helped
bring it into the world
and that's pretty special that's pretty
amazing
the macro thought is like it'd be
awesome
to try to be like one of the most
impactful people ever
um and i actually think it's possible
i'm 35 now
i still have a lot of energy i'm pretty
sure if i stopped doing this i would
just like wouldn't be happy
so i'm on some kind of track fall over
dead at 36.
yeah kind of continuing to work on the
stuff and it makes me happy and
that would be really awesome to have
that kind of impact awesome
uh three questions then you get to ask
me one to finish uh
most important book you've ever read
that's an interesting question um
i really loved zero to one that peter
thiel
wrote i think it's a really interesting
framework on how to think about
opportunities and how the world's
changing
and there are a lot of lesser lessons
and principles in there
that some of which are immutable that if
you understand them they can kind of
change your perspective
on how everything operates and why and
why the world changes the way that it
does and
what's happening in the world and i'm
very interested in that
so i enjoyed that book a lot yeah that's
a classic for a reason
right totally um sleep schedule so
i sleep five or six hours mateo and alex
over at asleep got me now
i'm a sleep convert yeah eight nine
hours can't sleep without it
if i can't get it turned on or something
because the user error i'm like pissed
at myself
uh what's your sleep schedule you know
and how's that changed over time
yeah it's interesting i'm like always
changing myself so i went through this
phase when i was in
here in miami at first where i would
stay up until like two or three a.m
like every single night and a lot of my
most productive hours are like between
midnight and 3am and that always has
been the case like no one's bothering me
no one's texting me no one's emailing me
um so i actually really enjoyed that but
i've realized i really need my sleep and
you know
getting eight or nine hours is really
really really important and
to some extent like the most important
things are actually just
making very good decisions and coming up
with really good ideas
and you know the more sleep that you
have the more likely you are to do that
and you know the happier that you'll be
so recently i've been
converting we're starting to go to bed
earlier bedtime's moved up
it's been a massive help and actually
the benefit of that
being in miami relative to the west
coast is i wake up like three hours
before the west coast and i get to clear
my plate
in the beginning of the day and i enter
the day
playing offense here's what you know
okay i cleared my plate
what do i want to get done today what's
important let's edit the schedule and
like let's go and do it
and that feeling of being able to wake
up and play offense every day
is just like a much better feeling and
way to live i like your approach because
it's a very relentless approach it's
just yeah let's go every single day
right yeah
uh last question is aliens are you a
believer or non-believer
oh this is an interesting question um
well
you know given that the pentagon
released
basically that aliens exist that
interestingly nobody talked about when
it came out they've released
all the footage there are people like on
aircraft carriers that
say that off of the east east coast
they some kind of craft whether it's
aliens or whatever ufos it could be spy
things i don't know but they appeared
every single day they saw them every day
these are not people that are gonna lie
they have no incentive to lie they work
in the navy so
i don't know i think we live in a really
interesting time
um yeah like is the bombshell
oh they just you know slowly getting the
public to be like yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then just bam here you go
and nobody cares and nobody talks about
it and
you know it is what it is i suppose um
edward snowden said though when he got
inside the system uh it's one of the
things he searched for and he didn't
find anything
which uh always is fascinating to me of
like
you know is it more complex than we make
it
well i don't know it could be more
complex it could be some kind of strange
aerial phenomenon it could be some other
thing about physics that we don't
understand
it's possible we just don't know but the
government has told us
now at this point and they're going to
release a lot of information i guess
apparently at the end of this month
yeah that might shock the world even
more than it did before around this
my conclusion on let's say like the ufo
footage is
if it's aliens and i put the narcotics
whatever that means
uh shocking yeah if it's something with
physics that we don't understand and
then we
learn it shocking right like amazing
whenever you have something that we
don't understand then we learn about it
like
there's going to be inflection point in
our knowledge
in our you know understanding of galaxy
or whatever but it's just like it's big
yeah let's see what happens right yeah
uh you could ask me one question to
finish up what do you got for me
um yeah we're
like let's fast forward like five or ten
years where are we at with crypto
obviously you know
so much about it how has it changed
how's it evolved where are we
has it taken over the world has it
supplanted i think everyone
thinks about it in terms of like the
technology yeah
to me it's just automation that's all
we're talking about is automation and so
it's an automated central bank yeah it's
independent it's dependable it's
predictable yeah it's all it's done it's
automation yep
uh all these decentralized open
protocols
empower automation every asset that we
used to have was physical in nature
physical stock certificate physical
bonds physical currency then they've
moved to this like electronic q-sub
version
you know now when you buy the stock you
buy an electronic q-sip
currency electronic q-sip yeah well it's
just gonna become digital and then once
you have digital assets i always joke
that like
right now if you wanna have an automated
system and any financial assets involved
it's like trying to take a cassette tape
and put it in a cd-rom player like
they're incompatible technology
that's true well if everything's digital
and now it's all compatible like who
knows what people are going to create
who knows but just things change fast
yeah and so to me like that's more of
what it is and so it's it's less about
like
is it a thing is it not it's just like i
think we all generally agree like
an automated world is where we're going
yep this could be a more efficient a
faster
more valuable world yeah and so like
this is a
piece of that evolution yeah um and so
when you look at through that lens like
this actually isn't that revolutionary
right it's more kind of
evolutionary type thing uh but then when
you like start getting in the details
you're like oh wait a minute like yeah
if you take down central banks or or
ship them of their power like
there are many non-technological
ramifications of that yeah
that start to change the world right and
so i think that like
that's kind of the lens it's more of
like an automation and then
where i think a lot of the the kind of
bitcoin crypto people get excited
uh myself included it's like okay what
are the ramifications as this becomes
uh prevalent and uh we don't know yet
yeah
we don't know it'll be interesting we'll
see it's changing the world
it's changing the world that's for sure
where can we send people to find you on
twitter or find out more about atomic
um yeah i'm just at jack abraham
atomic our website is atomic.vc we
actually launched a program recently
where people can apply to start
companies with us right we would love
you know people to increase access to us
if they want to start a company
come find us like we want to start
companies how do they apply for that uh
the website is atomic.vc future founders
i believe or you can google future
founders atomic it'll come up
um and yeah we'd strongly encourage
people to do that it's a fun place
we're having a great time but we're
building things that are really
meaningful too
that you know the intersection of like
purpose and fun is pretty interesting
so if anyone's interested in that they
can do it and we're going to build a lot
of companies here in miami so if anyone
wants to build a company in miami
you can have your cake you need it too
this is a great place and you know
uh there's some epic things to build
you're never gonna stop explaining miami
and i love it
everyone should come yeah awesome thank
you so much for doing this yeah of
course
thanks so much for having me great to
see you